I can't believe this has to be said
but fathers do not comment on your daughter's bodies
like either to them or to strangers
last night we went to go see a play put on by my daughter's camp
it was the whole camp it was all of these girls
and I was sitting next to this couple
they were super lovely like
they were just the nicest people ever
except for one comment that the dad made at the beginning of the play
he pointed out which one was his girl
cause I was like oh
who's your daughter like
we started chatting it was great
pointed her out she's up there in her costume
she's playing the lead role
by the way he looks at her costume and he goes yeah
that's a little too tight
isn't it and his daughter is bigger boned like him and my dad
but she's 13 and I couldn't help but think if you saying like
comments about how ill fitting her costume was
or how like
she looked to me a stranger he met fourteen seconds ago
my heart just like instantly broke for her
because I'm like I wonder how many of those little like
jokes her dad makes or like
comments to her face and you might be saying oh
he was just talking about
with the fact that it wasn't like a no
no that's not how we meant it
so dads don't do that or at least don't do it to me